so I was um gripped by a news story a
couple weeks ago that I'm sure a lot of
you were too so for those of you who
don't know there's a woman on a flight
from Atlanta to
Barcelona there was a woman who had
explosive diarrhea and they had to up
and down the plane and they had to turn
the plane around it lighted on fire I'm
assuming is what they did with it right
so what happened she had stomach
problems she was in the front of the
plane she tried to walk to the back and
she [__] up and down the a hold yo
let me tell you something if you haven't
seen the video or heard the captain's
call back to the
tower where he called it he was like
we're having a medical
emergency we got to turn around so I was
like this story deserves a
song so I wrote it from two different
points of view I wrote One Voice one
verse from the point of view of the
person who was just on the a plane to
Barcelona
he wasn't you know what I mean he was
just on his dream vacation mining his
own
business and then um there's the other
point of view from the person who
[__] the plan
okay here we
go it'll be all
right let me make sure I got
it
okay
I'm just seeing if I'm yeah I can do
[Music]
it on my way to
Spain well I plan my dream trip plan
this well by the way eventually there's
going to be two people
singing so when you hear that voice
that's the other person okay here we go
on my way to
Spain I play my dream trip plann this
for so long and I can't remember the
last time I had some days
on what's Happening up front
yeah sounds real
bad people are panicking did you hear
that scream what could it
be hey dude lots of people they're
running to the back they're coming fast
did you hear what that person just
said she just [__] on the plane
W and she's coming this
way she just ran right past you you've
got [__] on your
shoe Arin those your new
[Applause]
Js there's a lot of [__] on this plan
woo you think it's all from her yes
that's all her
[Music]
poop she [__] 17 times there are grown
people crying wait a
second is it too late to jump from this
plane that's verse number one there you
go all right this is from the
[__] that's also how I sign some of
my
texts my stomach so
[Music]
so got to hold it in please God hold it
in I think I can make it to the next
sty my tummies in
bubbles
I think I'll try a
[Music]
fart do you think that's
smart and then I'll just sleep the rest
of the
[Applause]
fly when I let one out and it felt so
good real good babe I got cocky in it
all
slipped
away I just [__] on the
[Music]
plane was this happening to
me well I need the bathroom but I have
to walk through rows 12 to
33 maybe it's not so
bad just act
casually nope that's hot lava poo I just
shot on his
shoe and I'm only
halfway I should have
taken the
train there you go everybody thank you
so much
for